okay hi everyone we are about to look at
a design for a command line interface
and Connor is going to explain this to
us
right so we've got a a number of things
to discuss but this is a little
open-ended um I'll just say for for the
benefit of others for those of us who
work here this is not something for 13-3
so this is not designed review per se
and there's no time pressure because
there's a lot of different directions
this could go in so we're just kind of
trying to scope things out
um
but uh there are some specific things
that I was planning to talk about but
that's just my agenda give us the
outline of what the heck the point is
here right so there's basically a thing
where you type Wolfram on a command line
it does something and you want to expand
what it can do to be beyond the 1988
input line output line
correct yeah so as I mentioned here I
mean there's basically two use cases for
improving command line interfaces in
Wolfram language there's the official
command line tool like you were saying
That's dollar Wolfram or or dollar wool
from script rather
um and then there's the case of user
authored scripts that want to provide a
a non-trivial command line interface
with kind of the fancy features people
have come to expect of of well fancy for
what they are on a command line
um so I have functionality that kind of
covers both those use cases but
um I mean this is a third-party wolfen
language piece of code
that is going to
just like and maybe you can remind me
um Chris for example in Wolfram script
when you want to launch a notebook from
orphanscript how do you do it
if you're running away from script
command and you want to discuss cooler
here here
I'm not sure you can launch a notebook
can you
that was what we had in mind that maybe
we never implemented it I think that's
the case I remember seeing something in
the documentation about that but I don't
think it's ever been implemented
ah
okay but the the point was in that case
it launches a notebook and then there's
a back and forth interaction through the
notebook interface
and in a sense what I think you were
saying Conor is that there will be a
mechanism where you could launch a
command line program and then have a are
you imagining a back and forth
interaction or are you imagining command
line arguments
command line argument so we're talking
about something that is it is built
purposely for to be used as a command
line tool okay
um so which I haven't excript has has
done but we haven't we don't have a way
to I mean
Beyond dollar command line and parsing
dollar command line we don't have a way
to let you specify I mean what we need
is something like an API function I
thought we designed this well no there's
two there's two things hold on hold on
so the first thing is Rule from script
is is totally focused on running Wolfram
language programs right that's all it
does and all of its options are about
where to run them and with what you know
options and and so on right
I think that's different from what this
is here where you know the point is to
be able to do other kind of auxiliary
operations like making packlets and and
and stuff like that running tests Etc
that's not running open language code at
least not visibly right
okay but but that's also Segways into
Connor's comment about users doing
things and I thought we had a plan like
five years ago just like we have
yeah we had a plan for a function called
command line deploy
Chris Cooley do you remember this
I remember it certainly
and the idea would be
but Stephen that's really not what
Congress got I'm just not trying to
write a launcher for Wolfram language
code that's what command line deployed
was a launcher for Wolf and language
programs he's trying to add capability
to to our Wolfram executable so that it
can take a set of commands and do
operations like Christopher was saying
you know build a packlet run some tests
it's not about launching it's not about
new ways to to to launch executables
that uh are built with Wilson language
it's it's really about no I understand
but but I'm going to claim that the
right way to think about this given the
comment economy that you want user you
know this should be a user addable thing
why not think of it as it's going to run
some code it's going to be often
language code it might call other
programs it might do other things but
basically it's a mechanism for saying
how do you take how do you configure a
thing
I mean that was what I understood from
Connor but the question is
yeah go ahead Connor if I could just
interject I preferred prepared an agenda
that covers from the low level parts to
I think the high level parts that you're
talking about Stephen I think I'm kind
of talking about all of it perhaps with
slightly different language or from a
slightly different direction but I've
tried to cover I think all each of those
use cases
um okay so I mean so one use case is
it's just like we've got separate things
right now for dealing with licensed
managers and God knows what else and you
want to wrap those all into a single
command line function
yeah basically
okay make it ill I mean people often you
know are familiar with using the command
line for things that are kind of
developer oriented tasks or kind of
administration oriented tasks so I think
having a yeah I got it I mean it's it's
a vernacular that has changed in 35
years
yeah 35 years ago
you know Unix
was big on having sort of small tools so
to speak
what you're telling me is that for
perhaps for reasons forced by signatures
and operating systems and things like
that people are preferring you know in
Unix
well I don't know right I think that
that that change is is a whole other
thing though I mean like for example
even apps like there used to be apt-get
apt what is it app search app info stuff
like that now there's just apt and you
do a sub command to to call it for
example
but I think well yeah yeah
okay so that's one thing is we need to
modernize and package everything
everything that can be called from the
command line
almost everything you're saying we
should package together in this one
function
and obviously an obvious question as
well from script should it be packaged
into the same function
I think much of Wolfram scripts
functionality should be yes so the I you
know uh the idea of I don't know we
could just see what's in here I mean run
a piece of code execute a file call an
API runable from language function uh
all of that stuff makes perfect sense
within this this this Wolfram command as
well I think the only aspects of
wolframscript that are a little
incongruous here are is that wolf from
script was kind of conceptualized as a
thing that can run wolf from language
code without there having to be a local
installation of the wolf of language so
it's a separate tool but that's a bit
it's a bit anachronistic
um and it's a bit what do you mean it's
an optimistic I thought it's modernist I
thought it was modernizing well
so the odd thing about Wolfram script is
that it
uh it kind of has its own way of
discovering which installation of the
Wolfram language is going to use if you
do have one installed locally
um so it's kind of a it's a second level
of configuration on where should this
command find the installation of the
program it's running which is a little
you know I think the more familiar thing
is that if I've put a program on my path
like if I've put wolf from script on my
path I would expect it to use the
version of the Wolfram language that it
was installed with so for example if I
were to run say python on my command
line This doesn't refer to you know find
the newest installations I understand I
understand it refers to a specific thing
but look I think this wolf from script
functionality is really very useful it's
just different and I and its name is a
little bit confusing relative to just a
wolf from binary
correct I mean I think it's useful for a
more Niche case which is the case of of
you know I don't have wolf from I don't
have a kernel installed at all but I
still want to be able to run certain
things
yes
yeah so we're and to be clear we're not
proposing removing or getting rid of
wolf from script in any way just
giving us a level of attention to the
the local command line interface as well
so you're saying many of the
commands here would be you know
transferred over to the pure Wolfram
function
some will be left only in Wilson script
and maybe the pure wolfen function would
add others
yeah correct
but I mean things like hash Bang
well from script would that then become
would there be a hashbang Wolfram thing
yeah I think that would be be natural
okay
because I really think there's some very
nice stuff to move from scripture and I
think oh yeah I agree
yeah
okay right but almost all of it can be
just zoomed over
Yes except you're saying the ability to
go to a remote kernel right but but the
point is that this is this is like
I think there's no problem here it's
just that we have two two you know two
different command line executables and
uh you know they share a bunch of the
same operations but with the difference
being that you know Wolfram script
doesn't isn't tied to a particular
kernel
yeah I understand it's a pretty pretty a
bit of a weird name for that and we
might need to rename well it was all it
was already a weird name
that doesn't that doesn't encourage me
but yeah okay all right so let's let's
dig into some of what uh Connor wanted
to go over I think I'm now I'm now at
least understanding where where we're at
sure uh so I'll just go through some
things so there's levels to this the
most basic is I've written some
functionality for essentially styling
things that you use on the command line
so this happens to just be a package
under my name but obviously If This Were
Made officials would work a bit
differently
um but there's a new function called
terminal style which you can give well
some expression to and specify some
styling parameters and you get output
that on a command line Looks
well styled as you'd expect
um now I'm going to mention something
quick because people may have picked
this out there's a very intentional
reason that this is the string red and
not the symbolic specification red you
know the RBG color object
and that that is because uh this is It's
like a pseudo color this is referring to
the color red in my terminals you know
16 you know like table of colors that
has 16 colors in it that happens to be
RGB you know pure red but it doesn't
have to be it depends on kind of the
quote style sheet that I'm using right
there's a color map and what I was
imagining though I haven't implemented
this is that doing this uses a function
piece of functionality called true color
where it does actually use the exact
color you specify you know the full 24
bit but so first question is why is this
not style of blah comma whatever
um so I went back and forth on that
though my concern was that
there's a lot of style things that you
can't represent on a command line easily
now maybe that's not a very good
argument but well what about the size of
the font can you represent that or not
no not something terminal support I mean
it's very constrained you've got colors
and you've got things like bold
underline
uh
oh uh whatever so close enough
oh I uh underlined yeah the errors need
to be better but
yeah
um and that's basically it like colors
and basic textiles uh some very fancy
terminals support things like images but
uh not really at the point where I want
to rely on that being a feature that can
be used
um
I mean as you kind of expect yeah
look basically what you're saying is
if you write a piece of code it might
have styling in it for a notebook
a very small subset of that styling will
also just work on a terminal
so one point of view is you just use
whatever styling you use in a notebook
and when it's rendered on a terminal
those things which happen to work on a
terminal will work on a terminal
yeah yeah that's one possibility I mean
style already does honestly sometimes
weird stuff like that you know in in
notebooks where it's like if you give it
a style but it knows how to render it'll
render and otherwise it it'll just be
unevaluated
right where the other direction too
which is the the thing of like oh I've
got a bunch of points I'm feeding to the
list plot I'll use style around them but
if you actually show the points you know
it's this kind of bizarre you know it'll
be a coordinate and the coordinate will
be rendered in red right as a piece of
piece God yes right
but yes that's pretty good
what happened there why didn't that come
out red
I'm not sure
I just don't do this often enough and
this is actually
oh
I wonder if that's a bug
no well that bug is more
nefarious I mean more okay
yeah
um anyway that that is a a point but I
don't want to get okay stop there I
definitely favor
that style just renders
if it
happens to be available on the terminal
and part of the reason I say that is
because you know there was a time when
terminals couldn't do Unicode there was
a time and they couldn't do this
the motion you know the trend in
terminals to do more it's a pretty damn
slow trend
but it is a trend
so maybe one question will be what if
some of the style directives can work
and others can't just render the ones
that can work and ignore the ones that
can't which is the same thing that
happens if you say use a font that is
just unloaded or whatever else just
doesn't use it
but I mean so
right let me see so it would it would
Pisces you would have style of hello
comma red comma something it can't
render it will show that entire style
expression in red or it'll show hello in
red and it will just ignore the thing it
can't render No No it should just ignore
the thing it can't render okay like it's
obviously not printing as the out input
form of the style anyway so fine it's
red but not but not 30 point size yeah I
think it's the right thing to do because
I really think we need to you know it's
only going to get you know you said some
things do images there'll be things that
do different fonts eventually maybe you
know and also I can imagine an
intermediate thing where you're in a a
special terminal
you know of some kind
where people wanted to do more
yeah that makes sense you know okay
right let's move on
right now one and again we don't want to
get hung up on this but the fact like
this this choice of using string red
there's a question of what is the
equivalent of that if you're just using
style
um I mean it could be something like
ANSI red or uh but I don't know I think
that um maybe we can have a symbol
that's like uh I don't know what to call
it you know terminal color of quotes
read
I I'm not sure that we should have
terminal red because my guess yeah and I
don't know my guess is that there's some
color palette different terminals will
have different entries in the color
palette and they'll be named and they'll
mostly have a name red but some of them
will also have a cyan right
yeah
I think a terminal color wrapper sounds
reasonable although I'm concerned about
what does it do in a notebook
well maybe default I think it doesn't it
doesn't really mean anything
right I mean it's it's all we have
default mappings what about but I'm
saying again this depends on something I
don't know which is if they're very
terminal dependent right like if if uh
oh I use the you know fish terminal or
whatever
um you know that that's nice looks like
they have standardized meanings
yeah they basically do uh right so maybe
we get all these standard ones and if
you're using some uh terminal that has
some weird colors that aren't on the
Wikipedia page or something then uh okay
I've got a different point to make one
of the things that's happening is these
are defined by Escape codes I might
actually want the string so we need a
mechanism for generating that string
so I think the string with the escape
code yeah I think it should be something
like terminal string of whatever well if
you say terminal string of style block
comma red it will generate it with the
Escape codes
we'll just return you a string which is
the you know the terminal string with
its Escape codes
right it would I mean the string itself
would have to be escaped though because
yeah I mean the Escape codes themselves
if they appear in the terminal they're
instantly like they're live you can't
kind of nerdify them easily
um oh I know so I know I know that's
fine that's just fine that's exactly
what we want
okay the point is if you're in a
notebook you want to be able to to see
the string
yeah but it's just terminal string of
that because you might want to put it
you might want to Output it you might
want to write a piece of code that
you know for example you might want to
save it in a file you might want to save
the thing in a file and then render it
in a terminal and see all the brightly
bright colors
no don't serve terminal style it's just
of style
herb yeah but by the way I mean what is
the What is the
right more generally what system does
the does the command line version
currently use to stringify stuff because
I use input no it doesn't use input form
right output form yeah
correct
so maybe it'll be worth having a
terminal form which is actually instead
I do
oh yeah right okay so you'd say two
string of block comma terminal form and
that would give you the thing that's
escaped with all the right terminal
stuff oh yeah yeah that would be very
reasonable it might actually already
work so uh terminal form of
you know it shouldn't be a well okay
right it should just be a terminal form
should be a symbol like output form
right no right it is that's that's what
just happened oh I I see right but you
could also say two string of blah comma
terminal form
let's see no no that's not the right
thing that's not the right thing it's
too well it's a comma terminal form
yeah two string is a second argument
which is the the you know the form to
use so but I think the this I feel like
the thing is that that weird kernel
stuff to work the problem is that that
is exactly what it's doing and the
Escape sequences in that string are
getting interpreted by the terminal
right so all good so so why don't you do
this no no in the output that so if
you're 13. 13. hold on hold on yeah
because
right that's wonderful beautiful yeah
okay that's exactly right
I mean it's a separate question whether
the whether the notebook front end
should interpret the terminal
uh Escape codes
which I can see an argument for it doing
maybe though I'm not worried it'd get
kind of weird quickly because it's kind
of it's a new kind of escaping and it's
also the fact that like a notebook
we already have things that are far
better for use in a notebook I think
this behavior is fine
it seems to me I mean this is that you
can save it in a file it's all good
I mean I don't even know what actually
there's something a little bit weird
about that if you say full form not
input form say full form at the end of
that line
yeah
I mean that's just that's just our
normal weird character encoding stuff at
work
yes
but it's not obvious that raw Escape
in input form is correctly rendered well
maybe it is I don't know
yeah what what happened there it's just
fine
I mean if we picked up the character
codes of that they'll be signing on what
this skip character code is but
it's fine
yeah okay
um moving on
moving on right so that's basic
formatting of stuff now I've implemented
and I have you can see here I've
implemented terminal form formatting for
test results I've implemented it for
uh let's see you can do URL read if does
not
exist.com and format that in terminal
form and you get you know a red
formatted failure
um and obviously you can imagine Alice
would extend other stuff but that's what
I've implemented so far
um so that's that's all of this input
here this was just in Wool from script
um I'm gonna drop now into this custom
interface I've implemented the Shelf a
couple of other things
um but obviously these would be in the
official interpreter eventually
um first I'll just mention that this
this terminal
uh has terminal forms set as the format
type of oh yep okay all right oh
actually that
should have in it should have I thought
well let's do this
well okay there you can see that
messages are getting printed in red
which is another thing
um okay
let's try that one more time options
dollar output there we go now it's
terminal four yep so
um reading page width from the term cap
uh no but it could we talked about that
before it's on my list
I don't know this is a meaningful page
height
uh
it's probably possible for some
terminals to get the currently visible
height of the page I don't know how yeah
uh same thing messages formatted red
failures formatted in red as well uh
other thing I'll mention is that print
output is understated maybe it's a
little too understated but um and also
uh in is written in bold whereas out is
just normal so it makes it a little
easier to visually parse your your
separated input and output so cool I
mean do we have anybody from graphic
design if we're really going to look at
those things we should
no no one from graphic design is here
okay well let's let's put that aside
let's you know there are probably a few
graphic design decisions like how gray
is the gray and things like that it
looks like you have two levels of grade
that you have available
and that's somewhat limited by the
obviously the named colors that are
available commonly two levels of gray I
can see yeah
um so that's basic colored output on the
command line uh if we go one level up
this is where we get to actually parsing
command line arguments so I've got this
example here this greeting.wls script
um and if I go ahead and start running
this
um let me just
walk quickly through what this does so
it loads various packages
um and then it has a symbolic
specification of essentially a parser of
a sequence of command line uh arguments
um we were just talking about the naming
this happens to be called clap because
I'm using a Rest Library under the hood
that implements this subtle command line
argument parsing logic that happens to
be called clap clap command line
argument parser.com but that's okay
that's fine
um so this is this is like it's a link
pack let's link to this Library anyway
so this is incredibly close to what we
were imagining for command line deploy
yeah yes I think it's probably Mainline
deploy I'll just say that I think that
became still in applications so what you
know I think the command line deploy
project became still on applications I
think you're basically right yeah well
maybe one one difference is that right I
mean my understanding is that these this
is for
this is for the Wolfram executable as
opposed to for your own whatever
executable right
well this is just a library like I mean
this is a WLS script it's if it's part
of the system anybody could use this we
might have a gigantic one of these
that's the whole the official Wolfram
command
um because these can be nested and built
up to be arbitrarily complex but there's
no reason that
we wouldn't give those same tools to
users who are writing scripts
it's the same mechanism
and like another thing we want to turn
into applications are these woven
scripts script files you know one of the
things so I think we can just
bring this technology back into
Standalone applications you know and and
then we can get kind of that some of
that original command line deploy stuff
that sounds good to me so I mean in
other words I don't know how you specify
a standard on application but this is
part of its
uh
uh I mean in a sense but here you don't
even need to specify it's just you just
write it in the source of the
application
right well how does it how does it come
alive
well yeah I'll show you so this is just
a symbolic object clap command and clap
argument do not evaluate yeah just
symbolic uh it comes alive when you call
clap parse so clap parse takes a list of
strings and a parser object
um and then okay so in other words what
you're doing is instead of this being
something
you know you have to have an evaluator
effectively an initial you know a boot
sequence or something or you know an
initial I don't know what the heck
they're called anymore when when when
you call Main
right there's a thing that runs when you
call May used to be called initial
instructions back in the day
am I making any sense
something goes that's just a scrappy or
something I mean that's just this you
know when you run a script it runs the
script and it's going to run it until it
hits this part that's sort of waiting
you know
waiting for the command line arguments
and it's going to take all those in and
it's going to you know
yeah I got it I get it yeah there's also
the question of whether
well whether there's an automated
built-in command line argument
you're saying for the Wolfram command
there will be a built-in set of command
line
argument parsing and actions
but you could
have
your own thing and then you pick up the
dollar command line and do whatever you
want with it
yeah right
yeah the thing that's a little funky
about this is
I I'm not really getting this okay in
Wolfram script where you have a hash
bangle from script
the name of that executor can be
anything you want the name of that thing
can be anything you want
because
and what you're saying here
is that this is a way of taking the
command line arguments from that
anything you want
script and doing things with them is
that right yeah and just to be clear
this is a hash bang wolf from script
script at the top here uh it's just once
it gets into code that I control
I'm parsing the the script command line
um I understand I understand so I mean
you're saying
I mean so it's worth pointing out and
this might be what you're getting at
though and tell me if it's not there is
a difference like Wolfram script has
compiled C code for parsing its own
command line arguments
um and if they're unrecognized or you've
passed it a file then it just runs the
file which can do whatever it wants it
wants so for wolf from script there is a
distinction between Wolfram language
code you know that's run after all the
arguments have been parsed and the
parsing step yum
this just eliminates that distinction so
in its Essence it would make the the
Wolfram command kind of this almost
extremely thin wrapper you know all it
does is run a wolf from language program
that parses the command line arguments
it doesn't do any kind of upfront
validation before starting a wolf from
Colonel another way to put that is that
right now Wolfram script doesn't have to
start a kernel if you pass it incorrect
command line arguments it can detect
that they're syntactically invalid and
give you an error without ever having to
start a kernel and this new mechanism
assuming it's specified the symbolic Way
by definition it has to launch a kernel
before it can even know if you gave it
correctly but I think that's correct
because it's it's right it's the same as
C right and C you have your main
function it takes ARG CRV it's just that
here you access our CNR v through this
dollar script command line so yeah yeah
yeah
I mean one practical consequence is that
if you enter incorrect syntax you have
to pay the you know 0.7 of a second
startup cost of the kernel to see a
syntax error which is not terrible okay
okay look look look look look look we've
got multiple things here okay yeah one
thing is we've got a binary you know an
executable whose name is Wolfram okay
that's case one
case two we've got an A an executable
whose name is fish or something okay
and that is a file that is a hash bang
wolfam script file am I right
uh conceptually sure yeah
well and that hash bang wolf from script
file has
command line arguments which are not
usually
well are they usually passed by Wolfram
script or not
yeah I mean I think if you're using
Wolfram script and no no if you've got a
hashtag file oh
myscript.wls if I write dot slash my
script.wls space
Fubar oh right yeah from script does not
touch those okay so that's the case that
seems to me the most interesting but
what you have here right that's exactly
what he's doing here
so okay so let's just understand what we
can do okay so one case says this is a
way of processing dollar command line
right dollar script command line or
whatever
and what's the difference between dollar
script command line and dollar command
line
what what's the difference between those
two
uh hold on it's formatting in output
form
um
you never remember exactly
I think that this
might drop the command name but we'll
just try it but would the dollar script
command line is an empty list for me
the dollar command line is something
meaningful but it'll probably be
different if you're calling with Wolves
what are you doing just just do it in
the notebook it doesn't that you don't
need to do oh well here here it's empty
because this isn't a script
when wolf and script does dash file it
starts the kernel in a big complicated
way and I think it might be using math
links so it's not a command line isn't
very helpful for a script so we set up
the script command line
with the arguments to the executable to
the you know right the actual original x
to the original thing that was typed on
the command line
right yeah so here you can see the
difference so progress was saying dollar
command line is this big long math link
thing script command line is the actual
useful stuff
okay all right fine all right fine so
what you've got is a utility for parsing
dollar script command line
yeah right now in the case of the
Wolfram binary the wolf from executable
I have no idea what you get for dollar
scripts command line
you appear to get nothing but presumably
in that case what you want to parse is
the dollar command line not the dollar
script command line
no but but what you want for dollar
script command line is probably those
things which are not peeled off as parts
of the built-in Wolfram function
peel off the built-in stuff then look at
what's left over then feed that to the
um
I I don't know I well it's wrong to me
it just seems wrong to me it seems like
what you should do is if you want to
give actual command line arguments you
know okay
in the Wolfram binary there's a bunch of
built-in stuff
either now built in or stuff you want to
add that's about authentication and
packlets and God knows what else okay
that's bucket number one bucket number
two is user added
you know command line arguments which I
argue should be prefaced by you know a
dash dash dash or something and then it
follows that with user command line
arguments am I making sense so you
distinguish them from the other ones
because otherwise the day you add some
random additional built-in thing that
blows up a bunch of things that people
have done as users it's going to be a
very bad day
do you see what I'm saying
right so we'd have some convention for
like you do dollar wool from I mean bad
name but custom command and then it's
some user
well I think it would be I think what
you would do is you would say dash dash
dash you would give the the commands
that were you know intrinsic well from
binary commands and then you would end
that with a dash dash dash and then
everything that follows that would be
user commands
that's what I would do well I think the
proposal here is that instead well first
I think you do Dash Dash is what some
some yeah okay fine programs use but but
um instead of that you could just frame
it as a sub command which is a lot less
weird right so you have a sub command
that's basically saying yeah we'll have
wolf from space make packlet wolf from
space you know run tests
and then I'll go from space you know my
you know custom command and now you're
in sort of custom command land and
everything you type after that will get
passed as some you know instead of it
being dollar command line it will be
dollar I don't know what to call it
it'll be dollar script command line
maybe okay sure
maybe but I think and the script command
line will just be my custom command
it'll be that sub command onward or
something yes yeah that's what I would
think yeah maybe it's first argument
will be the whole of the stuff that
precedes that as a single string
command line you have the name of the
binary followed by the you know the
arguments that are then possible or
manipulable
yeah
now for people who are adding custom sub
commands I don't think it would be so
weird to just give them this full list
because if that's like if they're
writing a custom sub command for the
Wolfram command it seems reasonable and
their effect use cases where some people
will will have a command that has
different Behavior depending on whether
it's like it's designed to work both as
a sub command I understand but I don't
think we should yes you can do that if
you say dollar command line you'll get
the whole shebang
the built-in commands and the user
commands everything
if you say dollar script command line
you'll only get the user commands
I it's just really important that we not
have something where there's any
possibility of confusing a user tag with
a built-in tag because otherwise we're
boxed in we can never add a built-in tag
well I think it's the possibility of
blowing up user code
yeah so I think the analogy is is kind
of like I mean we add new context to the
system all the time right
but we don't worry too much like you
know somebody external user Theory I
know I know backlit tools package
we're happy to collaborate because we
think that's pretty unlikely
same thing here I don't think so I don't
think we should assume that here because
I think people will use short you know
Dash X blah blah blah we should not
assume that
you're talking about something different
though you're talking about like a flag
right Flags people have very you know
Dash X Type names but if you have a
whole sub command I think I would not
worry so much about sub command names
colliding okay I think that the point is
the user's code is only triggered if
you're using their sub command
yeah I understand I understand well okay
I I would think it was better you can
have it as a sub command but you know
or you can you know abbreviate the sub
command with Dash Dash or something that
is the user subcommand thing
I'm not sure well I I I'm not sure what
you mean I mean so first just as a you
know
piece of modernity or something I think
flags are generally kind of not not
really on their way out but they're not
used nearly as much as they used to be
okay well fine but then then what I'm
suggesting is what you say is so I know
what that wolf from Dash anything is
that's not relevant oh Dash CLI okay
that's just mine yeah yeah okay fine but
then then if it just says
Wolfram
Dash CLI or whatever and then
you know custom if you want to give it a
name just custom and then after that
everything that follows is part of that
subcommand
right making sense and then the custom
thing maybe it needs a name that
reflects the fact that it's going into
dollar script command line
foreign
are you worried about like flags that
come before the custom
that that you know it's not clear where
they go yes I'm I'm saying most of the
time you're not allowed to have Flags
before the sub command
really actually not that is possible
with this Library it's actually default
okay
you might do something like that
yeah okay so what I think should happen
when you do that is this
script command line should give you the
stuff that's after it should give you
the first element of JavaScript command
line should be the name of the binary
which should be all the way up to the
word custom
and including the word custom okay
that whole thing as a single string
so something like in that case script
command line would be
black wolf from CLI
custom and then the next argument would
be notebook website and the next
argument we build
right right that's right
okay whereas dollar command line would
be the whole thing broken down including
the dash B and the custom as separate
elements
that's what I'm suggesting
right the only suggested change I would
make is that this I think if we wanted
to be the first element fine but I think
we should break it down into its
constituent components because if this
is something like pretend it's not that
wouldn't make it a sub list then make it
a subject yeah all right parsing of
these is not trivial so
all right
but that's sublist though okay okay so
so then
all right so just so we're clear then if
it's a hash bang wolf from script thing
dollar command line and dollar script
command line will be the same
right
right wait wait you said if it's a
welcome script thing
oh then they'll be the same
if it's a wolf from command then they
will be different
right so
okay now now let's go through
actually sorry it should be technically
hash bang wolf from script should still
have a different script command line and
command line it would be if you do
hashbane wolf from that they'd be the
same oh yeah okay but fine
okay all right let's go back to your
clap Library thing well let me just make
sure I got this recorded right so we're
saying a custom I mean basically script
command line I think you said equals
dollar dollar command line which makes
sense because there wouldn't really be
any way for them to be different
um
we should move on here I think yeah okay
yep there may be some further details
there but but let's go back to the
okay so now
or what you're providing here is
basically a function that is very
similar to URL pass once you look up URL
pass
please don't look it up in the command
line just look it up in there now look
it up properly just press the press the
I let's actually look it up there so we
can see the details and options and so
on
okay so this makes sense to look down at
what it does in the examples
right yeah I'm familiar with this
function right
but so is this analogous to what you're
talking about
analogous yeah I mean some online parts
right let me show you what this actually
does so I
yeah maybe one difference is I assume
that uh with the command line you have
to tell it more about what you're
expecting right like if if you say oh
I'm expecting another level of
subcommand here or if you're saying oh
I'm expecting a sequence of of strings
then it needs to parse that differently
unlike URL Parts where it kind of parses
everything the same every time yes
yeah but but then how does this relate
to the way that uh for example
you know form function
is a ui-based way of pausing things yeah
I think it's I think it's more like form
function where you sort of have to right
you have to sort of tell it about what
what you expect right
yeah
it's like API function or form object or
even interpreter where or even just a
generic pattern like whatever thing you
specify on the command line uh
optionally ought to satisfy some spec
yeah okay fine fine
okay this looks very hard to understand
your version of this
well that's why we're having a meeting
to discuss but I mean the basic idea is
I mean first thing is a name and I had
the usage I'm gonna like this is the
usage message for each of these
currently if you want to you know peruse
that real quick
but I don't understand this at all I
mean okay so we've got we've got a list
and it's got things in that list right
um
wait sorry I mean basically that parser
the whole clap command thing is the same
as the the first argument to form
function
all right or really I think it's a form
object isn't it
yeah uh yeah I think command is the same
thing as a form object or like you know
conceptually
yeah it's very similar it's a symbolic
specification of kind of a grammar I
guess that you need to satisfy with your
arguments right and it's a little
stylistically different in that form
form object
kind of maybe bends over backward to not
use any special symbols it's all just
like lists and associations and stuff
whereas this has some of its own symbols
yeah it might not be right okay so let's
let's take a look
at okay could you scroll up to the top
perform object again please
sure
okay so it has things like defaults and
and auto submitting okay and and whether
all right okay
so hold on let's let's take a look here
okay
so I have a question why is it the case
you know in dollar
script command line right now
it's an inhomogeneous pile
of you know argument
elements you know this that and the
other broken into lists
don't we already know
or do we not know do we is it the case
the only thing we know is that it's a
collection of tokens separated by white
space
is that the only thing we know yes or
can we deduce okay so it's a collection
of token separated by white space
correct yeah
okay so now
what kind of a grammar
is allowed in describing the collection
token separated by white space
right and so that's that's right wrote a
little bit on this but I mean that those
conventions have changed over time right
so like what we see in Wolfram wolf
script is kind of the the single leading
Dash specifies you know a top level
switch between different areas of
functionality that's kind of fallen out
of favor for a sub command name that
doesn't have a leading Dash
um so you know this is arbitrary in some
sense but the grammar that's common
today is you have a sequence of command
names and sub commands that don't have
any prefix you know so Wolfram packlet
build is like a hierarchy of sub
commands that Nest together
um and then those can have
uh two types of arguments positional
arguments and non-positional arguments
um positional arguments always have to
take a value non-positional arguments
don't have to take a value specified
with flags
right non-positional arguments always
start with a single Dash or a Double
Dash
um
so it's a key value thing so you say
Dash Foo and then space bar and that's
value key Foo value bar correct yeah
so why don't I
okay
so
that's a mechanism we don't readily have
in the language is something which is an
alternate
of named and unnamed but essentially
what you're trying to do is you're
trying to fill certain arguments
you know can we think of this thing as a
function where you're trying to fill
certain arguments I think yes
okay so the naive thing that you would
do
well I don't know okay I I don't know I
have no idea what the schema should look
like
um what on Earth is this thing that you
have on the right just what on Earth is
it
there sorry this thing or yes what an
earth is it well why don't I describe it
and we'll see if we get so the basic
idea and I'll pull up the usage message
so people can could reference this
um so a command is made up of I mean
there's essentially like if you wanted
to find a command you have to know its
name and you have to know its arguments
and optionally it can also have sub
commands so those are the basic elements
of a command
um and these sub commands are themselves
at least in this representation clap
command instances so there's this
arbitrary hierarchy of commands with
arguments and optional sub commands
um arguments have a name and they have
some action that represents how they
should be processed when the parser
encounters them so this right
so that action okay there's a couple of
options it can either like this is a
named key uh it can either set that
named key to some scalar value this is
freaking horrifying it's just horrifying
look the things should return basically
some Association just like form function
does
you shouldn't have any of these kind of
weird shortcut or I'm going to execute
at the time I'm pausing type things
am I making sense
the goal of this function should be to
return an association that represents
the the thing that's supposed to be
represented by all those command line
arguments
right the I mean one of the I mean
there's some nuances there though
because for example if you specify this
up front you know the computation
essentially is in the symbolic
specification you get things like error
reporting for free right if you try to
specify multiple values for one of these
things clap parse can handle that if
you've told it whether you want to allow
multiple values or not you could do that
in the case it's the exact same thing
with form object exact same thing oh
yeah and execute in the middle of this
thing it's a big mistake you want to
separately say okay this there's two
steps this it's like natural command
line
understanding okay just like we have
natural language understanding we don't
try to we don't have an evaluator that
runs at the time of the of of pausing
you know it's like you pause first you
make an expression then you evaluate it
right I guess maybe I'm not
understanding which aspect of this you
think is evaluating and violating that
principle and the thing about setting
that's just crazy you just want to have
something where the goal of the thing is
to take you know everything has a a key
and a value
what you're going to return here I
assume is I mean anything which is
actually evaluating anything at the time
of parsing is a mistake right this is
not set as in system set this is just
terminology but it's silly because it
should just say look what this should
look like is
problem is
okay
let's just understand what a possible
grammar looks like
so you've got something which has
commands and sub commands
well and for somebody who's in a sub-sub
command
so I think
I'm trying to think is a restricted
I mean because I think I don't want to
get hung up here because this this is
not like this is kind of equivalent to a
different specification that might be
something like this option takes a
scalar right the fact that it's called
set and that sounds mutable and scary I
think is
that just happens what it happens to be
called and the clap Library so I
mirrored that but conceptually it's not
relevant yeah right it's not relevant I
think what I want to focus on here is
semantics not the name what would you
call it
it might be I mean I don't know exactly
it might be something like scalar or
required value or it might be the
default and if you want anything other
than that you have to specify something
just be clear of what we're trying to
return here with commands and sub
commands and so on is it or is it not
the case that what we are trying to
return is a flat Association of keys and
values is that true or is that not true
I would say not true so let me show what
this actually returns so if you do clap
parse what I have it returning is a list
of
essentially pairs between command name
or sub command name and an associations
this should actually just be Association
queue though I don't I don't need it for
this just show it just show us the
return value a return value from
something with sub commands
okay uh well here but I just Echo this
then I'll run the script
uh so let's say I pass it say hello
and why don't I copy out this extra
stuff
by the way this should just run in a
notebook this should just be a thing
where you give it a string and it
returns whatever expression this is
right is that not the case so you're not
messing around with prints inside inside
scripts right can't you just take this
function clap parse and just run it and
it returns an expression
you can yeah so let's just do that no so
we're not messing around inside this you
know crazy harness here just take it and
put it in a notebook and let's just give
it a string that is your dot greeting
dot hello just check that out put it in
a notebook
okay I don't understand this at all
right well here so okay first argument
is obviously greeting
we're gonna call the say hello sub
command
okay I'll load this again
that's just inert yep
um
right so that's what you get
okay so let's understand this okay let's
not look at the thing on the other side
let's just look at this okay
okay so what does this saying
I don't so I don't get it at all
let me explain and I think it's a
mistake it's similar to well I mean I
think it's it's just it's uh
right I mean it's just another structure
like what form function does yeah like
what form page does form object but it's
Messier
okay for one thing as far as I know it
doesn't have a notion of hierarchy no it
doesn't
no because this does
okay so that's one reason it's more
complicated because we have to represent
that this is a thing nested inside
I got it I got it
but so What's that name and language oh
that that's just just setting there
right those are those are kind of the
the conceptual like the name of this
argument
um so this is the key under which you
will access it in the association in the
parsed result
all right let's see what this looks like
if there's a sub command
well there is a sub command that's
that's say hello uh if I don't pass it a
sub command no no it's an error no no no
no no no no no you said it's
hierarchical show us another level of
the hierarchy
oh sure okay so if I wanted to add
another layer of sub command like maybe
it's I don't know say hello
like uh the command would be something
like okay I'm gonna add another layer of
hierarchy so say hello has why is that
another level of hierarchy that this
looks like it's the same level
well it's nested inside this say hello
command
right so
because again that oh yes
okay just
kind of a mess but put in a command yeah
say hello uh bye bye whatever you want
to do bye sure all right so that's
specification for that I just need to
say it takes zero arguments
and now
uh put it and say hello and then bye
right bye
so now we end up with an element three
element list
whereby that's not making clear that
buyers are sub I mean you could imagine
a say hello say you know bonjour and
each one has a buy Sub command but
that's not represented in that output
expression right this is like so this is
kind of like a file tree like a file
system tree right it's the full
everything on your file system this is
like a file system path it's a specific
sequence you know a specific set of
things if you've got both say hello and
say bonjour and they both have a buy
subcommand that representation does not
indicate that that only allows you know
it doesn't indicate which
command that subcommand is associated
with
right
yeah and but I think that's so let's
look at this device so greeting has two
sub commands say hello and say goodbye
this subcommand I'm just call it fooks I
don't know what it would be but these
are these are at the same level in the
hierarchy so they're elements in this
list I know I know they are but but the
foo is not make the second thing food
not buy not bye make the second one and
Say Goodbye make its command Foo as well
okay okay now show us what that returns
okay now now put now say say goodbye in
addition to no no no no no no no no no
no
both say hello comma Foo and Say Goodbye
kamafoo
that's what I did this is say hello
in a single in a single line in a single
input line say goodbye Kung Fu comma say
hello comma Foo
oh sorry like like that I mean there's
two different sub commands yes
this is not grammatically valid you
couldn't write this why
because you can't execute multiple sub
commands in one invocation it's like
saying write a single you know symbol
that calls two functions at the same
time
you can't it just doesn't Okay
okay so that's only there's only one
command which then has sub commands
yes so in other words in that pausing
thing at the top those are alternatives
yes alternatives
yeah okay how does grammar rules work
does it not have a mechanism for this
and does it not use the alternative
symbol for this
uh
well it does have the Alternatives there
but if you look at any examples of
grammar rules you give it usually a big
list of different things don't you yeah
I think you do yeah
right so this is basically saying the
appliance command you know matches you
know he matches this this grammar
and the grammar contains okay so but
this is a very similar setup right turn
off the stove or something there
is like commands and subcommands at some
level
that makes sense
yeah
I'm just trying to
all right so what you're telling me is
that fundamentally I mean even though
with flags and things like that there
are multiple different things that can
exist on a given
there's only one command per are you
telling me that the way this parser
works there's only one command
command line invocation is that correct
one invocation yeah one command there
could be multiple Flags
yes so the other arguments we're dealing
with there could be multiple things of
that kind
yeah okay so look I've got another
analogy okay if you look at um
oh my God what's it called
um the thing that executes shells the
shell
from
what is it called run process no run run
process
yeah run process yeah
okay so see what that's doing with with
exit code now run process
okay
so run process is just giving the white
space to limited elements of the command
line
so what you're saying is
you're at the other side of that pausing
the command line and let's be clear
there are two types of things on the
command line there are flags that occur
in any order
and then there is your command with its
sub commands is that correct
yeah and also positional arguments but
yeah what kind of positional argument
compositional arguments or positional
arguments within commands position
arguments within commands I mean
everything is within subcommand right
there's like there's the root command
then there are sub commands so every
position for Flags which are not in the
in the sub command
well flags are a type of argument to a
command right they're kind of like our I
can say Dash V and then say say goodbye
can't I
yes but Dash V is an argument to the
greeting command
so that's what's a little weird here is
that you can see yeah
okay all right so which is why you end
up with this nested structure where each
command has Associated arguments I get
it I get it
is it obvious we shouldn't just use a
tree
I think it's all too weird it's too
weird probably look I think that the
more common thing we would do is these
days is to use rules rather than nested
lists
but I mean what you're saying is
okay
right it is basically a stack
like what you're saying is this is a
one-sided a very one-sided tree
well this output I don't I don't know
that I would call it a tree
it's yeah I don't think it's a tree I
mean it's just it's just a I mean it's
literal it's quite literally a stack you
have a command and a sub command okay
well here's a way to do it right and
arguments at each level okay here's the
way to do it right it's a way to do it
okay the question is can a sub
subcommand repeat the name of a command
no I mean the name could the name could
be the same but it wouldn't have to call
the same code if that's what you mean no
no but could there be two Foos though
because otherwise the structure that I
would suggest is something that just is
a an association
like these sub commands are like they're
kind of like contexts or something right
it's like saying you know okay we're
gonna run this isn't a very good design
but it'll be something like this you
know Wolfram space tacklets space create
space some arguments and then separately
of Wolfram space pack space you know uh
build or something like that so packlet
is a sub command and then create or
build
so it's scanning until it gets to that
next supplement so so one way to
represent this type type this in okay is
you know Association
okay greeting
Arrow null Association
comma
so you know Foo Arrow nobody there can
be they can be the same two things one I
know there can be collisions but then in
addition this is also just conceptually
wrong because you know
again it's like there really is a an
ordering it's important
oh but you get the ordering here this is
the ordering there is only one it's a
it's a tree that has to go down just one
branch it goes sub come on come on sub
command Sub sub command subscribe but
the thing is the thing is realistically
what you're going to want to do is
you're going to want to say you know for
example maybe with pattern matching or
maybe with whatever else you're going to
want to say oh if the command is you
know quotes packlet comma quote create
then I want you to run this code and if
it's quotes packlet comma quotes build I
don't want you to run this other code
this is not a useful structure okay okay
okay so then right then which is what's
happening here just to illustrate you
know I'm I'm doing the place I see it I
see that yeah I see that but this is
don't mix the execution with the pausing
of the thing
I don't think it's mixing here right I
don't think I am okay
we've got a separate function that just
does okay fine you got that separate
parts does all the parsing and it
returns this basically stack like
representation and then replace is just
actually running something based on that
representation okay all right so the
question is what the most convenient
representation is given that what you
are typically going to want to do
is treat I mean okay so here's a here's
another radical idea okay
what about if you go back to the left
hand side there okay
what about something which says
um
I don't know we can call it script
command Okay function script command
of greeting of quotes greeting
and then no no no comma there now it's a
sub value so now of
script this is very XML element
well I'm just trying to understand how
you use it right because
yeah
I mean this seems like a worthwhile
exploration I don't know that I love
this syntax but right and after greeting
though you would have the flags or
something right yeah
script I mean this might be overly
verbose it might just be no you don't
want script talk you just want to you
just want an association though right
yeah
or it might have to be a list because
maybe you can have Flags more than once
which is horrifying the way XML like
yes and also again
the list is I think semantically more
appropriate because these things can be
they're positional right the order is
important
I know yeah associations are ordered but
it's implicit
also I don't even know how it works
because you know not all flags have
values
I mean some flags are like you know
you'll write you know dash n space 12
and other ones it's you know just dash
dash V
yeah
or maybe or sorry maybe you're already
explaining that in the part in the yeah
I want to know how do you typically use
this so this is this is an alternative
right so you know it might be useful
Conor like if you could just show like
cargos sub commands just to see like
roughly what these how these hierarchies
work
sure well I mean if I so cargo h
and for people to know cargo is the rust
language build tool so cargo's got
cargo build or rabbits or just just look
for a second though that so that the
first are the flags then they're the sub
commands right and so now I've tried
doing one you know cargo test or
something like that and let's see it's
help
or oh it's hell yeah yeah
right so cargo testing that doesn't have
any Sub sub commands but it has lots of
flags
yeah those flags when you put those
those flags I would say cargo test
maybe dash dash you know features
something or other why doesn't it
that's this is a convention whether the
the convention okay so this is a weird
it could be good news it could be let me
see so right there's a single Dash This
is actually something that wolf from
script is kind of annoying about that it
I think it does not follow the modern
convention so basically
in uh most of the like new tools you can
do something like you know that like for
example you can do Dash you know LS
space Dash lah or something like that
and that's the same as doing Dash L Dash
a dash H yes right so so what that means
is you cannot have in a command like
that a multi-letter
you know flag yeah and so the convention
is normally that single dashes are for
single letter commands and if you do
Dash La H it'll expand that and double
dashes are used for multi-level or
multi-letter okay
yeah and and what's happening here also
like what's represented this is kind of
a convention for this this is something
that has a quote short name and a long
name so I can say dash dash features
yeah
but maybe maybe is there another one
like cargo build or something that'll
have a sub sub command
um all right I don't know I just want to
know how you're gonna use this in other
words okay you've got
basically what's going to happen is
there's something that's specifying a
command here
and that has got to dispatch
to some actual piece of code
right and the replace thing is not the
right way to do that
right I mean I I had thought of
something like a command pattern
something or other and there might be
you know clap parse and again the names
suck but clap parse replace and you've
got actually I might even have an
example of did I save no no no look look
look look look
look well something where the replace
action and the parse action is one
function that's made to make it more
ergonomic okay well hold on although no
that's the opposite just just earlier
you were saying that we should not con
you know that the parsing and the
execution should be separated
no look look no I'm saying once you've
got the pass done okay here's another
case that we have another pattern is
event handler
which also is only very simple events
yes I know but the main point is that
then there's a list that says event Name
colon greater than action right so just
the best thing here would be if the if
the executor of this is basically a
great big list of if you see this thing
in the command line
with certain patent variables you know
so what one would like is something
where
you know
what the hell is this
I'm just thinking out loud this is but I
mean all the syntax here is wrong but
you could imagine something like a
specification like what you were saying
where the Handler is specified in line
on the right hand side okay guess what
that's like that's just like API
function
mm-hmm yeah
right where it's picking up certain
arguments
and then using them
there's an important difference though
which is that API function you know
ultimately there's one function you're
ever going to call sometimes maybe
you'll have it so that depending on an
argument you pass the API function it'll
sort of Dispatch over many different
functions but there's no clean way to do
that right I mean you write a big switch
or something like that well right here
I'll dispatch
has that
URL dispatch dispatches on
with rules dispatches on on a on a sub
you know element of the URL
right yeah right but that's that you
give it different API functions or form
functions for each
you know you don't put the URL dispatch
inside your API function you put it
outside right okay look look here's an
important Point here
this interface this command line
interface is not very combinatorial
unlike what we're used to in language
design which is deeply combinatorial
this is something where there's a
command or sub command this is a very
as you said it's a stack or
if we draw out all the possibilities
what do they look like they look like a
tree presumably
well you know in other words what are
all the possible
commands sub commands Etc that you could
get
right at the top level at the command
level
there are five different commands let's
say well I don't know the initial
command might be one one thing but then
there are five sub commands each of
those sub commands has variable numbers
two three five whatever it is right and
and yes it's a tree and and basically
it's it's if you're it would be super
weird to have it turn into a dag and if
you did have it as a dag I think you
should just have to copy your code like
it's yeah okay fine so it's a tree but
now the question is
when you execute that tree what you want
to do is you go to a leaf of the tree
and
each Leaf is a different execution
function
right there's no sharing of the
execution functions each Leaf which has
picked up certain commands sub command
with various Flags
goes to a leaf the leaf knows it has
these flags and it was this named leaf
and then it has some code and so to me
what what needs to happen is each of the
flags picked up at each level you know
what do you feed to the leaf I think
what you feed to the leaf is an
association
that can tell maybe it's a list I'm not
sure or list of associations maybe it's
a list of associations from each other
levels
and
okay look here's what I would propose
okay
that the full thing
no no look look look look look look look
look look
you gotta decide the flags are not going
to determine what the okay let's take a
right the flag shouldn't determine which
Leaf you end up in right agree with that
so so okay so every leaf is a sequence
of commands and sub commands Okay it's
labeled by sequences commands and sub
commands do we agree yeah
okay I think so yeah so then what I'm
suggesting is that the execution layer
like an event handler is just a great
big list of
basically commands and sub commands Okay
so to write it out write it out so let's
of and then a sub list here actually you
can just have an association here it's
in the list it's an association the
whole thing in association no list no
list just an association
okay the first element is the list list
the key is the list
top level command whatever it is command
comma hello comma you know sub command
one comma sub command two yep arrow and
then
right you're being given at that point
yes flag one blah blah blah now now
those that might have to be a a set of
sub-associations because those flags
might have repeating names so you might
say command one Arrow flag one blah
Etc et cetera et cetera right
right no no so write that out in that
Association that Association itself
no no you don't want no no no no no no
in that Association is it it's an
association of associations
okay the first element of the
association no there's no flag it's
command one Arrow the first element of
the association is command one CMD one
arrow and then the flags associated with
cmd1 right
okay and then sub command one and the
flags associated with that
but then you have to repeat you know
command one sub command one every for
every sub command of sub command one
right what do you mean
well command one appears in here more
times than necessary because like this
the keys of this Association I
understand that yeah I understand that
and possibly then then one could have
lied that and just make that into a list
I see so I'm saying rather than
repeating the keys command one et cetera
although I'm suspicious about that but
okay so that's one possibility the
second possibility is command one blah
blah blah blah on the left hand side and
then the right hand side is a list of
associations
do you see what I'm saying so you don't
have to repeat the keys
so get rid of those keys and just make
the list and get rid of the association
at the beginning there
okay
all right
and then it's why not thread it or
something but yeah
yeah why not threat us I agree
no actually I don't agree I don't agree
because
those flag values
oh no maybe I do agree here's what I'm
suggesting about it okay
I don't know whether this works pattern
matching wise
okay so so threatum there
sorry I I don't when you say thread I
know the function
command one just make come on one a sub
list
no actually come on I'm sorry I'm sorry
I'm sorry I'm sorry come on one Arrow
and then flag one blah blah blah
actually then this is no longer an
association this is a different this
different animal
but that's possible it's just a list get
rid of the outer Association get rid of
the outer Association in which case then
the way that you look up your particular
command or sub command or something
would be with pattern matching
yeah right and now we're back to
something that is essentially what I
know we're just with cruel instead of
lists Tuple
okay but now let's think about how you
use this okay what does the pattern
matching look like I don't particularly
like option C but anyway what does the
pattern matching look like to say you
know what we want
is something where you can have a
function f
where you very cleanly say F of list
command one command Future come on blah
blah blah blah
and then you like pick up
there's no there's no script command
there's no script command it's just look
what you're doing is this is a part
there's one command that pauses the
thing okay and then you're just applying
standard functions to evaluate it
yeah well I think we should try to
clarify right now there's there's kind
of two different routes we're talking
about there's something like the URL
dispatcher route where the the patterns
are mixed in with the computation
specification right
um and then there's the uh there's like
the clap command route where nothing
about how when you match where like
where is the computation injected you
know there's nothing in this about
computation listen we're getting
confused here I'm trying to clarify yeah
right okay when you do a parse
you're going to get a single come on one
sub come on one sub come on two list out
right there's no association of these
things it's a single list
yeah okay this this specification makes
sense when you've already parsed
something like this makes no sense
that's the specific that's the
specification of what to do
yeah right so what I'm suggesting is the
function that specifies what to do the
the big switch the dispatcher right then
I'm thinking how do you write that code
and the answer is one possibility
okay now maybe there is some function
that wraps around to do this but the one
possibility is it's command line sub
command one subcommon two colon greater
than
make a separate thing make a separate
yeah so
there's no parser here it's just the
computation here
just well Handler this is the Handler
okay
so then that
colon greater than and now
that function is going to be passed
something with a bunch of flags in it
and I don't know exactly how that works
that that argument should probably be
yeah I think it should probably be yes
what it should get is a list exactly
what we had before the fact that those
are repeated is no problem in other
words okay no actually actually now I'm
I'm thinking okay so here's what I'm
suggesting there's no match queue
there's no match queue Stephen I'm not
using this I I'm not using this to
represent like this argument has to have
some conceptual value I'm just writing
this to illustrate what is the structure
of the article okay okay okay okay but
but but then okay what I'm saying that
function is passed if you write below
what that function has passed
underneath there as is the association
okay
um well I think you're just going to
want to write it in an input line okay
Association and then uh a key
and then the key is quotes Quotes no no
no no I'm sorry list
cmd1
comma
flag value flag one
arrow that whole thing no that whole
thing the whole thing the whole list is
a key the whole list is a key no no no
no no okay okay
Arrow value one
okay
that's probably not a string but it
doesn't matter yeah it doesn't matter
okay
okay now let's say I don't know
subcommon three
or whatever
another sub list another sublist in here
another sublist okay sub command three
flag seven
you know whatever it is flag seven goes
to whatever
what is the oh the I think the flag
seven is confused but
this sub command 3 is sub command of
yes it's one of the what I'm suggesting
is that the evaluator here
you know for every sequence of commands
and sub commands Okay you're defining a
function that's going to handle that
what does that function get given it
gets right because these are all the
flag values for each of the different
sub commands at all the different levels
yeah yes that's right because then it
can choose oh I want the flag from the
command level this flag name I want to
use that or it says it also needs to
presumably be passed maybe this is a
separate argument but it needs to be
passed uh you know the dispositional
arguments to the sub command
and then the name of the packlet right
it might have that as a numbered thing
perhaps or it might have why not this
you know you have this handle object you
have you know this function which which
it gets given the flag spec and it gets
or probably gets given the argument spec
and the flags back and the argument spec
is just a list of all the positional
arguments of strings or maybe just one
big string I I don't know and then it
gets the flag spec
two arguments one that is of positional
arguments and the other that is of named
arguments
yeah basically right yeah
so the first argument would be
I would already the first argument
should be the positional ones but it
doesn't really matter yes I agree with
you
yeah the flags are like options right
so so then
the first slot will be a list
can we assume that we can you know for
example break it at spaces and stuff
like that or or is it just a string and
we can't touch it
this is kind of a question about how
clap works
no I mean like if you if you want to if
you have a string with spaces in it that
add the command line you need to use
quotes to group them okay fine
we shouldn't do any processing like that
right well yeah
sort of has to do that processing right
like it will break it up into well it's
not even clap it's the it's the
operating systems parsing of the custom
line because
the shell yeah rather
yeah Michelle handles it clap doesn't
um
okay but this positional argument thing
can't there be multiple positional
Arguments for command one
right so positional argument one the
value of this might be some scalar or it
might itself be a list I think what it
should be is that that first slot should
be an association CMD one with no no I
think you can't have multiple positional
Arguments for uh you know if you're
using the sub command you know if you're
using wolf from space packlet space
create you can't have any other
positional arguments to packlet
right
okay I don't completely understand what
what what's possible there but it's
either that just a homogeneous list of
positional arguments or it's CMD one uh
its positional arguments sub CMD you
know subcommon one Arrow illustrates
positional arguments I'm not sure which
of those is correct I would say though
like non-root like commands like if you
have Wolfram packlet build let's say we
shouldn't assume that Wolfram doesn't
have a positional argument because it
could
so then in that case the first argument
has to be
CMD one arrow and then a list Sub C and
D1 and then a list
of the orgs right
well maybe it actually should be list
cmd1 Arrow its args and then list Cindy
one comma sub command one args and so on
so consistently
so so you'd have it so that uh
right because because the right so you'd
have you you can't do it quite like that
because if you had a two sub commands at
different levels with the same name it
would there'd be a collision
right so you have to refer to sub
commands by the path
oh I see which I should just write yeah
so the key is the key is a path yeah
and then we just consistently refer to
sub commands by their path right because
that's true of the slot 2 thing as well
but we are uh oh yeah that's true
together it could be that hypothetically
but uh yes nobody I think it has to be
right because it's the same problem of
there could be a collision of two
subcommands of different levels of the
same name
like if I go from space packlet space
Wolfram right that's a sub command of
packlet then there'd be a key Collision
but so sorry you'd write command one you
wouldn't write just sub commands two and
all right come on come on yeah
we will command one comma sub command
one comma sub command two right the
whole path
yeah
yeah there
so
hold on hold on hold on hold on
hold on I think the better thing for
that second slot would be
that there's a consistent top level
backbone for the association
and it either is the positional
arguments or it is an association of the
flag arguments
so for the second slot
write out the same thing that you had
for the up above
like the the second
version of what no no for the first slot
but you had first slot the second
version of that that thing there make a
copy of that I'd copy that and now
instead of pause one I'll two whatever
it is just make that an association
that says flag one Arrow blah
flag two Arrow blah etc etc etc
right
I think that makes sense and then
yeah now you might need to pattern match
it's a little bit a little bit ugly to
pattern match on those flags but
probably not too bad
um well okay this is assuming you're not
pattern matching on flags but instead
you're just passing those any pattern
matching on flags is done in the in the
processing of the evaluation function
and the evaluation function is called
based on the command subcommand sequence
right I I would assume okay so two
things here right I think first thing is
that once we're using associations like
this
pattern matching was kind of unpleasant
right I would assume that that you would
be you know you're calling look up and
so on and I think that's fine it might
be worth actually having a different
first argument that's instead just the
sequence of commands and sub commands so
that basically the first argument just
tells you what function am I running
here right which will let you sort of
dispatch and then once you know what
function you're running you can then
just look up into these associations and
say oh by the way what was the value of
that flag just like you would be like
optional value and stuff like that but
it might be better then to package the
whole thing in association and pass just
a single thing to the to that function
on the right hand side
well actually you know what the command
you'd have a different function hold on
hold on look at the look at that form of
the Handler object you know what the
left hand side is because it was the
thing you know what the function what
the command and sub commands were
because they were the left-hand side
that got you to that function
yeah
so if you really wanted to pass those in
you would say x colon on that thing and
then password is pattern matching oh
sure sure okay that's true that's true
yeah fine
um so just as long as you know what keys
you you expect to be in these
associations I think it's fine
right but I do want to say that one
downside of this approach and it's not a
bad one but if you've got all of these
things on the right hand side like this
is I think we should discuss one level
out of the syntax right now like this is
kind of uh okay so this is the Handler
object that gets passed okay so this is
I mean what would this actually how
would this be used would it be something
like you know CSU say you know and let's
say script
command line parse of you know args and
then it's like
this thing is the Handler object
uh and you know as we just discussed
this there's like
right this gets passed two things
um which are so first slide args and
flags right right well pause args and
I'm gonna say options because Flags
implies Boolean but um anyway
so then you do like what replace on no
no no no you just do something like
pause args of you know listen you know
command one yeah sure would look up but
but for pause args it's it's safe to
just you know you know it's always going
to exist but just try you know command
one comma command or you know comma sub
command one comma sub command two
right like that that's a key though it's
not uh it's not part right yeah it's not
part a single bracket yeah yeah single
bracket on a list
yeah with a list there of command one
command two yeah yeah so we'd say you
know oh that's the name of the packlet
we want to create so then we're gonna
say you know packlet create of that and
then we want to know there's no value
equals it's just partly created that
thing there's no side effect
yeah sure so you know create yeah create
pack and let's say there's some flag
that's like oh do you need to you know I
don't know is this uh is this uh
a fancy packlet right then then you just
say comma you know fancy packlet you
know inside the crate pack let's suppose
there's an option to create Packer
called Fancy packlet you'd say comma
um
I'm not sure why you say no oh no you're
right so because that is it is one right
so it should be first positional
argument is the packlet directory and
the second is the build director or the
the output directory name
but double brackets Right double bracket
Parts yes double brackets yeah yeah
yeah fine
uh yeah right and then and then right
and then let's suppose we have the flag
that's the fancy is it a fancy packlet
or not so just write you know comma
um you know fancy arrow and then the
okay sorry so
second Handler
no no same same handle same Handler
we're just doing a flag right so so
suppose there's an option to create
packlet that's called Fancy packlet well
there's extensions
well but I want to do like a Boolean
flag or something just because it's
Messier uh but
food resource
identification is a more realistic one
yeah sure but anyway uh right that's a
Boolean flag so option Now options of
and it will be a list
will be two and then another layer of
list and then the inner list you're
going to say you know command you're
going to say you know wolf from Packer
create
because this is going to be an option
for create right does nobody feel that
this is horribly verbose
well maybe it is if you can have flags
at every level and you can have
positional arguments at every level too
then I think there's no getting around
it right
well but why I mean I don't have to have
that level of verbosity in this
specification now I don't I know we
don't like this because there were
places on the outside and we're trying
to have a unified object but I don't see
any reason why it's fundamentally the
case that we have to repeat this stuff
when this function is already you know
deeply tied to this command path listen
guys I have to go you can continue but I
have to go
um yeah okay well obviously there's a
lot to discuss here but yeah but but
maybe maybe right I mean one one other
idea would be I mean I'm gonna disappear
but you should continue
sure all right thank you okay
maybe go for a few more minutes but I
was gonna say
I'm not sure how satisfying this is but
we could have an object right that's
like uh
you know like a command line argument
object which sort of you can you know
includes all this path information but
you can basically query it in a in a
simpler way
yeah though I will say I mean I'm a
little uneasy about this overall
approach of just having these functions
on the right hand side I mean I'm not
sure what the right design is but one
thing I like about this specification
right is that if and I think this is not
crazy to assume I screw something up
when I'm writing this right like let's
say I forget to handle a key or uh I
don't know I forget to handle a value
here it's very clear what the fallback
is because it's just this replace fails
and it goes to my default case and it
prints something about well hey there
are some arguments you didn't handle if
I screw up something in this kind of
specification let's say this doesn't
exist or I access a part that isn't
actually guaranteed to exist you know I
I change something in this specification
but I forget to update this Handler
object now suddenly these things are out
of sync and it doesn't fail gracefully
because this option just I don't know
although although I would I would say
it's a little bit of a I mean maybe if
you have explainable pattern errors it's
not a problem but it's it's a bit of uh
well but there's no opportunity for a
pattern error to occur here
right like if this doesn't exist it's
just a part out of bounds error there's
no nice no I understand I understand but
I mean I'm just uh right I guess the the
case would be you know I I think I
generally agree but I think that the
case for having it be a function is that
it kind of forces you to write a pure
functionality for each of the cases as
opposed to you know you get back this
object and you're gonna do pattern
matching on it and oh I hope that I have
a pattern matching case for each of the
different
you know parse cases and it is also
repetitive in the sense that up above
when you wrote out your you know the the
parse specification you list out all
these commands and now you're going to
list them all out again and just hope
that they line up
um yeah well that's the thing I mean the
Holy Grail here would be some and this
might be too horrifying to contemplate
but you know where you've got and I I
did kind of a experiment with this but
you know you've got something like oh
God why is this not formatting right
um
you know something like and I'm not
proposing this exact syntax but like you
know that basically right and then on
the right hand side you can just use
this bound name so if it like if you
apply this and it matches
uh you just you know the specification
is the
parser and it's the cop you know thing
that right specifies the computation you
get all of it in one you know I just
this is a random point but this this
would be possible to do
with uh there was some meeting a few
weeks ago where we talked a bit about
having a pattern construct with a name
like
canonicalizing pattern or something like
that and the idea would be that it's
similar to pattern where you know the
you know the colon operator but where
you can give it a sort of a function and
and so the idea being that you can tell
it
you can basically tell it I want you to
you know
I want you to for example uh match if
this thing is an underscore string but I
don't want you to actually bind you know
I want you to bind some other value to
this you know to this symbol if that
makes sense
right so like you'd have something where
um
uh
right where we're basically the you know
there's as it does the the pattern
matching you know when it matches
something it will sort of run a function
and then bound the result find the
result to the symbol which kind of is
what you need to do that here because
you need that clap ARG thing you know
you don't want to literally match uh
like you want to actually run something
what am I trying to say you need to
actually like what you want to bind to
name is not literally just the thing
that's inside their place you want to
find something that's like more
processed right
I can't hear you Connor if you're saying
something oh sorry
um oh yeah I was saying I mean you you
don't necessarily need that mechanism
that might be one way to do it because
like in this case you know if your
specification is actually something like
this your whole pattern is not really a
wolf from language pattern at that point
so the fact that you have to be using
pattern name binding syntax is kind of a
cheat I I think I think I I patterns
that aren't patterns I think are very
dangerous yes I agree which is why I
wasn't seriously proposing this but it
would be an easy answer to how do you
get the computation how do you bind the
names without using a function
the
I think a construct like that might make
it possible for to do something like
this where it is actually a pattern
yeah
but yeah maybe I mean I would worry that
the rules around it like you know what
is because like fine for this specific
thing inside sure but then how is how is
clap command matched against you know
the sequence of strings essentially like
this this whole thing is not a pattern
either so
it's a little odd
right well anyway I mean I don't know
what I guess this was not
I think we should wrap it up yeah you
know the people who are this is
basically just
you know ECE meeting Personnel we we can
kind of follow up on this anytime we
want I don't know how deep you guys want
to go with this I don't mean today I
mean we could have a working group sort
of thing or maybe Conor just wants to
take some time to integrate the things
that have talked about or maybe Connor
and Christopher want to work together or
something
thank you all people who stuck through
this very long live stream